[Musique]
Dakota dépassant l'entraîneur de jiu-jitsu satellite
une époque de façade Delia Lucy Tata Anwar
très fin par Ginobili sans nom aussi
Falcons l4 possible
oui un mobile la chatte Pelican calme
électriquement Tuskegee personne dans mon
équipage n'est tu sais que extensible près d'un
développement politique
[Musique
] c'était un boisseau là-bas et maman
me raccompagnait à l'autoroute jusqu'à la route principale
et les attendait les bus que nous avions l'habitude d'
aller à l'école dans un camion certains des enfants
ont été envoyés au pensionnat mais je
ne l'ai pas fait  aller
au Canada 150 000 Amérindiens
dedans et peut-être que des enfants ont été arrachés
à leurs parents et emmenés de force dans des
pensionnats c'était brutal et
traumatisant on estime que plus de
6 000 d'entre eux sont morts de malnutrition
maladie abus physique suicide ou
mort de froid après  fugue peu de parents
ont pu tenir tête au gouvernement
dans l'église mais certains ont trouvé le courage
[Musique] Les
députés Mary Jean et William ont
célébré leur 40e
anniversaire de mariage e  Cette année-là, leur maison à
Wrexham au Québec est devenue un refuge
pour leurs enfants, petits-enfants et
autres qui sont venus à leur charge au
fil des ans facilement de l'autre et
quel garzooka Massey je l'ai eu en
nous réduisant à ne pas garantir que le magazine pour adultes
n'est jamais allé au pensionnat  l'
institution fédérale dont le but même était
de dépouiller la langue des enfants autochtones la
culture la famille et l'identité j'espère que je suis un
prodige
hier oppa sana quelques années plus tôt
le père de Megan avait tout essayé pour
garder sa voix près de lui mais la GRC
la branche armée  des Affaires indiennes
est intervenu et l'a fait arrêter, il
violait la Loi sur les Indiens en refusant d'
envoyer ses fils à l'école no para para ser
écoutez la posture militaire dans votre laboratoire ici
avec l'esprit qui a été conféré un
passeport de prisonnier modèle awara poo pourri écoutez le
pays nama Holika
[Musique  ]
l'école même ethnie était située dans
un peu CB Québec quand les
frères et soeur Maggie Jones sont rentrés chez eux l'
été suivant les dégâts avaient été  en
fait
Lucas un civil à médical d'un
espace disque tokahana piquant qui Posca
viscosité mallamma Paul Paul
Ciolino rasca Mozgov à l'écoute de Madhava Kumasi un
poly visité en tant qu'apologiste commercial
exposant qu'il avait un plan pour sa plus jeune
fille qui n'avait que cinq ans
personne  l'emmènerait au
pensionnat, il cacherait Megan pas d'inimitié
commune grue grue 12 un groupe Walla
Valley alors ils recommandent MATLAB pour
l'AP capitaliste recommandent la tentative d'un
coquelicot de Vaca venant de moi impliquent une
comédienne Janita
une autre arcuti de una batalla de la
mulana lyriquement de Foix dalla Alex Nick
parce que le fil raggedy Palakurthi blemish
et les deux biscuits sur notre caméra le
bus scolaire passait chaque septembre pour
récupérer les enfants père et mon boo
yah ferait également le tour
au début de l'année scolaire père
booyah  qui parle couramment l'algonquin faisait du
porte-à-porte dans la réserve avec une
liste en main pour s'assurer que tous les
enfants étaient partis pour l'école et que
chaque  fois
le père de Maggie John disait au
prêtre que sa petite fille s'était enfuie
au lac Petra éducation/argent Jesus amo
pavot Sarah vo La Marseillaise mapa
tabria Jesus Tom oppa Cowen Concha de
mapa no para cada team oppa not noise al
cascade de ba GA mapa  Les affaires d'Opperman
de Genesis Allah a5r chaque jour limite est
un repos moka moka sur Isabel Josefa
dans les maladies avec ouverture une polka
confortablement
quand le père burger vous êtes tous finalement partis
méga John pourrait sortir de sa cachette
[Musique]
elle passerait des jours à marcher autour du
lac  où elle était en sécurité,
il y a le bon analyste politique américain
Joe Corbin pour 40 émissions avant Jennifer
hola doctora Janelle pizmon Alaska
et plus quand Bashar de lave vision d'
avions nanofarad commanditaire de massage cachaca
faire Traviata Junia aplomb votre budget
le matin avant que le père Oh Blake
ne se présente  elle retournerait dans sa
cachette au sous-sol Megan a
pu vivre avec ses parents et
grands-parents parlant algonquin jusqu'à l'
âge de 7 ans  après quoi elle a fréquenté l'
école primaire locale du village voisin
Megan a réussi à éviter le
pensionnat, mais dans un amer coup du destin, le
pensionnat l'a rattrapée
quelqu'un proche d'elle victime d'abus
au SCI magnifica a agressé sexuellement son
gazpacho dorita merde politique
hommage à la personne recommander une cigale ii opossum
exquis MCB ou une araignée mémento pc mater
Muffet
à Melissa Vegas Kosovich ce jour-là la
fille heureuse et insouciante que Megan a
cessé d'exister
cyclomoteur inapproprié Scavo
Deepika connecter papa veillée d'une
promotion si une école privée une semaine d'
utilisation n'est pas une affaire cruciale
magazine jamocha marié très jeune à
l'âge de quatorze ans elle est propre depuis
23 ans
mysticum M Casas de la la Paz cassette
Démocratique Taj Mahal Molly
son mari William pipette C ne lui
a jamais parlé de son séjour au
pensionnat jusqu'à ce qu'il décide de
parler  avant la Commission Vérité et
Réconciliation
au lieu de genres pas un grand casting d'une
Epoque magique par mouvement sur la
chanson rajasah le père de mon fils Dell respecte les
abus
[Musique]
nous sommes un peuple continu honnête wha -
takanori Je souhaite juste notre société à
William Packett C  se souvient de l'été
avant son départ pour le pensionnat
au sud de Nia le premier ministre même Lauren a
visité une idée supplémentaire qui
apparaît ici qui sait que la vision éthérée
m'apaisera imaginez d'accord
- etana quoi - Daniel la personne
exacte inaudible Ebert William n'avait que
cinq ans  vieux quand il a été envoyé pour
dire difficulté en mathématiques pensionnat
chaque enfant a reçu un numéro avec lequel il est
71 depuis des années William a été victime d'
agressions sexuelles répétées il peut encore
entendre les pas dans les dortoirs la
nuit psychique à mes yeux il a tué n'importe qui
seulement sept travaux de Bostick que vous
allez construire viril laissez-la monter, elle
apparaîtra avec seulement le casse-cou veut
poser c'est la clé
[Musique]
si sûr
Oh juteux ok  ay virgule ici
quelqu'un aide je devrais appeler
[Musique]
William a grandi en ayant peur de parler le
prêtre lui avait ordonné de se taire
deux fois il s'est enfui deux fois il a été arrêté
par la police et son père booyah qui l'a
récupéré à la gare un été
il s'est confié à sa grand-mère une femme
de foi très forte Makai Mary
Amica dis-moi en Jésus les gens disent être
bien empoché parce que quand je dirais
au réalisateur de chier mais elle
avec une cabrona comme une Elsa - ok mon cher
ils ont créé un lepellier avez-vous  mets ça les
casser puis un jour son père qui
était souvent absent a fini par croire qu'il
disait la vérité
on va pas déranger les gens c'est des gâteaux des
glaces ma mère savait ici
t'es juste un humain quand t'entends ma
voix tu remets la gueule  Kingman
Chili Girls dirige Zeppelin, elle a esquissé les
deux paradis sont égaux pour Salomon Tibet
voir que c'était un choc brutal qu'il a dû sauver
William
[Musique]
à la fin de l'été, le père et le fils ont pris
un canoë et sont partis pour le camp familial
plus th  à une centaine de kilomètres de la
réserve
[Musique]
personne ne trouverait son garçon là-bas
sohcahtoa Kazuko merde idiote merde de silice
mais l'église catholique n'en avait pas encore fini
c'est mieux tracker père booyah était sur
sa piste aucun enfant ne serait autorisé à
s'échapper par peur  d'autres suivraient
avec l'aide d'un aîné mais nous avons tous
trouvé William au fond des bois
Mariana Japon il n'y a pas de poisson ici qui fait
le surplus de Pelican c'est tout Mittman
mérite un caissier être une personne Angela
magnétisme chronique si vous jouez aujourd'hui nous
considérons lakeyanna par  enjamber une
exposition CFL Lamoille dire la rétrogradation
mobalage solide en aucun danger complètement
lavable fournir dystrophie très ici pour
vous disponible chaque boîte ici Apache
pour ressentir l'amour le billet lié
voir un domaine spécial cet animal en
maîtrisant un membre de la ricotta fromage
alpha  y au poivre même rouvrir voir
l'épave en poche claire une jolie
prof mobile à capuche bleu
surtout chimio par une [ __ ] Apocryphe
jusqu'à juste vaincre la sécurité et  Le
père du livre d'Acushla à la Commission, Booyah, a parcouru
la région ABCB pendant des années en s'assurant
que tous les enfants se rendraient au
pensionnat.
grossière indécence ses
victimes six enfants autochtones du
centre commercial LexA et des œufs donnés de la région de Victoria
William et Maggie Chen ne faisaient pas partie de
ses victimes, mais le père qu'ils ont
abusé William n'a jamais été poursuivi
malgré le fait que son nom ait été
mentionné à plusieurs reprises dans les comptes d'
anciens résidents  les élèves de l'école Semak ont
le pensionnat a fermé ses porte
en 1973 vous
orte
la bouilloire et le code de la réserve des premières natio
s dans le sud-est de la Saskatchewan [Rire
] Lindy
a Kakaako a a réuni sa famil
e ils attendent des invités spéciaux d'accord
laissez-vous aider Lita Goodwin est  A 90
ans, elle a parcouru près de
mille kilomètres pour voir une
petite autochtone qu'elle  n'a pas vu depuis
plus de 60 ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lyndie ik un coq avait cinq ans quand son
père est mort sa mère Amy maintenant une veuve
devait trouver du travail mais plus important encore,
elle devait trouver un endroit sûr pour Linh
Le père de dia Amy, qui avait connu la
dureté des pensionnats, l'avait
prévenue qu'elle ne devait en aucun cas
laisser Lindy il y a Lin dia, qui vit maintenant
avec la mère célibataire au chômage,
était devenue une cible de choix pour
les enfants des pensionnats issus de
familles vulnérables de nomades ou
semi-  les familles nomades étaient particulièrement
ciblées pour Amy il était impensable que
sa fille lui soit enlevée maintenant je
sais pourquoi nous vivions avec la maman de Goodwin
avait demandé à mrs.  Goodwin Lita pour l'
aider à me garder en d'autres termes, je suppose que
la pensée de maman était parce que mrs.  Goodwin
n'était pas indienne, vous savez qu'ils la
considéreraient d'abord, alors maman lui a demandé de l'
aider, elle voulait me garder
[Musique]
la famille Goodwin vit près de la
réserve Le mari d'Amy avait travaillé pour
eux dans le passé Amy a maintenant demandé à être
embauchée  en tant que femme de ménage,
mère et fille ont vécu avec les
bons pendant deux ans, deux années cruciales
qui ont protégé la jeune Lynn dia d'être
envoyée au pensionnat. La plus grande
crainte d'Amy est que sa fille unique soit envoyée
ici à labret, l'un des plus anciens
pensionnats catholiques du
pays comme tant d'autres c'était un
lieu de maltraitance généralisée
[Musique]
cette photo de l'école illustre l'
angoisse ressentie par les parents qui campaient
sur le terrain et leurs tipis ils
avaient abandonné leur vie nomade pour être
proches de leurs enfants mais  on leur a
interdit d'entrer dans le bâtiment
au lieu d'être arrachés à sa
famille
Linh dia a pu avoir une
enfance paisible avec sa mère dans la maison Goodwin
[Mu  sic]
Lita Goodwin vit maintenant en Alberta, elle
voulait refaire le voyage pour sceller l'Inde à
nouveau, elle est venue avec ses deux filles
tout ça Lita
[Musique]
J'ai toujours pensé à toi Joe
harcèle toujours tout gentil
Je ne savais pas que nous avions fait ça  un bon
service Ashley Clements salut Lindy la
présente à certains de ses huit
enfants ils sont une famille heureuse fermée
sur le pont ils parlent et regardent de vieilles
photos tous leurs
souvenirs reviennent que je me tenais près de la
brique de verre quand maman a dit qu'un  dame
et sa fille venant à la façon dont
je repensais à maman et moi et à la
façon dont les bonnes ailes nous ont aidés, elles sont
venues et ont dit auriez-vous de la place et nous avons
dit oui,
mais avez-vous réalisé en tant que petite fille la
raison pour laquelle  tu es venu non non je ne pensais
pas qu'elle était juste une petite fille heureuse
[Rires]
[Musique]
ensemble ils visitent la maison où ils
vivent avec Lynn dia et sa mère qui
est décédée depuis
oui c'est là où nous vivions en bas ouais
l'un d'eux était  ma chambre brownie nous l'
appelons le cagibi elle nous a aidés à nous
protéger nous étions protégés mon rassemblement n'avait pas de
souci merci dites-moi onze d'abord
je me lisais en tant que femme et non en tant
qu'enfant
plus tard Lin dia a été autorisée à aller à l'
école à l'extérieur  la réserve une
école blanche qui avait commencé à accepter des enfants autochtones
pour l'amener à l'école sa mère s'était
arrangée pour qu'une personne en qui elle avait confiance la
conduise à la ville voisine il y
avait comme si c'était une route de brousse
avant que cette route de gravier soit ici c'était
un  boisseau là-bas et maman avait l'habitude de m'accompagner
jusqu'à l'autoroute jusqu'à la route principale pour que
maman m'accompagne jusqu'à la route ou à l'
école les écoles m'attendaient trop vieux
elle veut pour toi une bonne
éducation je veux dire ouais c'était toujours
quelque chose  qu'elle insiste toujours sur cette
éducation parce qu'elle ne l'a jamais fait et
connaissant maintenant l'histoire de tout ce qui
se passait, je pense que c'est incroyable
ce que je pense que ma grand-mère a fait, je
pense que c'était très délibéré de sa part, je suis
reconnaissant pour w  ce que ma grand-mère a fait parce que
je ne peux pas imaginer à quel point ma vie serait
différente si elle ne faisait pas ce qu'elle a fait,
c'est-à-dire soumettre une réserve intérieure sur la
côte nord du st.  Lawrence Seaway
ici, deux enfants sont montés à bord d'autobus scolaires
destinés au pensionnat, il y
avait à peu près 300 kilomètres de
chez eux, mais dans le cas contraire, vous devez vous
dépêcher David va me rejoindre Nick et son
neveu gigawatt peuvent-ils souhaiter qu'ils
puissent aller à  pensionnat comme tous
les autres enfants du monde vous
vous avec la série nous les avons rencontrés dans le
tipi familial le seul sur la
réserve
chaque fois que Bell Dominic a dit à son père qu'il
voulait y aller sa réponse était claire
Jonnie Pakistan sur Gaza yoni tip
réservé  table table a-t-il fait écho à ma
technologie jaune D philia alors oui personne donne un
chiffre Apache Sri Lobo seulement quatre seront
vous avez une personne votre solde
[Musique]
ils finiront par exécuter
Toby Scott tous ne le désirent pas J'aime
le gamin Belize ici Liz ça va  être
Sharif si nous choisissons un scapulaire Balance pas
longtemps maintenant le voir palace no Java désolé
[Musique]
le père de robert était un gardien du feu une
personne donne moi non non désolé non pero vivo
palette de crayons de codage remya pr  ocess la
tentative de circuit personne en Amérique sa
mobilité gamma mu voir Andrea ADT
Schulter APIs passer Rizzo dia devenir en
guerre le pouvoir présent vikelas Alta civil
un coup sur un Jaguar cub un point Rockwell
développer une maladie un jaune Satan est un
tabou le pélican cccc est sur  le juif
ira sur ma tâche aujourd'hui keke guat organise
des séances de guérison pour des amis qui sont
allés dans des pensionnats il est un
ardent défenseur de la langue et de la culture inu
nous avons trouvé la résistance amérindienne est une
histoire peu connue une histoire de personnes qui ont
risqué  tout une familles qui ont défié
l'église dans les agents indiens de
communautés entières se déplaçant pour protéger
leurs enfants des pensionnats
[Musique]
comme les Innes de PAC culte II sur
la côte nord de la st.  Lawrence
Seaway et neo cheese Ojibwe en Alberta ont
appelé les coureurs, ils ont fait un effort pour
garder les enfants hors des pensionnats.
Je ne savais même pas qu'il y avait
plus que comme il y avait un tel effort
fait par certaines personnes, ce que je trouve
génial
et je  pense que cette réunion est juste un si
bon moment parce qu'avec le rapport Vérité
et Réconciliation qui est
horrible, c'est une horrible
histoire horrible mais c'est quelque chose de bien
comme à cette époque, tellement de racisme
ressemblait à ce que je pouvais
imaginer à ce moment-là  mais nous avions une famille
qui a aidé ma grand-mère et ma mère et n'avaient-
elles pas qui sait si nous serions ici
ou ce que je pense que c'est euh c'est une très
belle histoire en ce moment surtout
plus de présentation merci beaucoup
Chappelle télécommande LED aha
château de Gosselaar livre appréciable  immersive la
qualité vocale Parag à qui est le
résultat à propos de ce moment est notre traitement final de
toute urgence Sofia la marge est
terminée
[Musique]
dramatique spécial camus  como para Butler
mm digit span Scalia a des
missions complètement claires potentiel clair Kinnear
[Musique]
vous